a lot of polling places had long lines
but not here astronaut Shane Kimbrough
is the only American to cast his ballot
today from low Earth orbit he's aboard
the International Space Station about
250 miles above the earth the ballots
get sent up just like ice cream yeah you
don't get a freeze-dried ballot it's all
it's a it's a little less fun than that
it's all done electronically okay fine
so not like ice cream but still the
polling place has a pretty sweet view
fellow astronaut Kate Rubens who
returned to Earth last week also voted
from the ISS there's actually some
fantastic folks on the ground that get
me an absentee ballot before I i
launched and it got sent to my my home
address and the absentee ballot address
is a lot low Earth orbit Rubens and
Kimbrough exercise their rights thanks
to a Texas law that allows astronauts
most of whom live in the state when
earthbound to do at NASA calls vote
while they float the county clerk office
for whichever County they reside in
generates a ballot it's given a mission
control who uplink it electronically the
astronauts then get a special code from
the County Clerk office that allows them
to access their personal ballot and get
sent back down to Mission Control and
then delivered to that county clerk's
office but now NASA is gearing up to
send people all the way to Mars there's
a very good chance that those first crew
members that make the trip to Mars
there's an American among them they'll
be gone during an election season most
likely because your trip to Mars is
going to be about the two to three year
range but what happens when people begin
to settle Mars permanently there's a
whole world of kind of space legislature
that will be explored as we begin living
in space more permanently but if those
laws do work out martian americans
should vote early transmission from Mars
to earth can take 20 minutes or longer
and if you want to show off your vote
better pack your own I voted sticker
ahead of time they one of the drawbacks
about having to vote in space you don't
have to wait in line but you don't get a
sticker